if you're looking for ways to disrupt
your standards master time management
and like yourself first then this video
is for you will say oh Lisa how do I do
this and I go do this this this and this
I give you the steps and the next thing
they say is mmm that's so hard I heard
once if you don't have your agenda then
you're gonna work for somebody else's
agenda that your perception of me after
I tell my truth is actually none of my
business need motivation
watch it top 10 of the leaf nation
what's up in seven my wine or disbelieve
and I believe in you I believe in that
amazing thing you have inside you that I
want to see burst out into the world so
let's get your motivation to attend and
have you believing in you grab a snack
and chew on today's lessons from a woman
who went from struggling as a single mom
on public assistance to becoming a
millionaire entrepreneur and
best-selling author of seven books
she's Lisa Nichols and here's my take on
her top ten real success vol 2 enjoy
alright let's kick things off with rule
number one disrupt your standard I run
into so many people all around the world
who are living this duality one I want
more but two I don't want to disrupt
what I have and the challenge is in
order for you to have a break through to
the next level your your your standard
your average and your ordinary has to be
disrupted people say oh Lisa how do I do
this and I go do this this this and this
I give you the steps and the next thing
they say is mmm that's so hard I'm sorry
did you think your breath taking life
will come on a merry-go-round did you
think you're gonna do the swings and get
there you're gonna sweat so get up ready
to sweat get up ready to forgive the
perceiving Li unforgivable get up ready
to take the higher Road even when the
smallness in you wants to get engaged
avoid the fight because the fight keeps
you in the little you when you're
committed to being the bigger version of
yourself yeah you gonna have to say some
things you never said and do some things
you've never done so you can meet the
man the woman you've always known
yourself to be I love this clip what a
great lead I was smiling throughout the
entire video I think it's so important
to understand that the actual steps
don't matter as much as the mindset as
much as the decision that you will raise
your standard and every single big
breakthrough that you will find in your
life will come as a result of making the
decision to change what you are no
longer willing to accept in your life
when you raise your standards to that
point that's when change starts to
happen thank you Lisa
we're gonna kick us off let's move to
rule number two create micro wins this
whole piece of my book abundance now I
wrote it a while ago and it's amazing in
terms of just talking about and breaking
down
what's the difference between a macro
win and a micro wind and a micro win is
that smaller goal that's you could see
it's attainable you get that instant
result and most people are chasing the
macro win all the time and they're not
looking at all the micro wins that they
can feel really good about to get them
to that macro result if you create 5 7 8
10 micro wins guess what now you're in a
rhythm now you're building some
consistency now you like the way it
feels and then before you know you look
up and go whoa there's that macro win
that huge goal that I thought was a
hundred miles away it wasn't a hundred
miles away it was seven eight eleven
micro wins away I love her energy and
how she bounces I'm watching on a
trampoline I'm like I'm bouncing
alongside her and she's doing it a huge
fan of this message I think too often
we're only thinking about the big vision
the big picture and then we don't
actually do anything with the keys you
want to think big and act small think
big towards your big dream your big
vision but then do something and
recognize that that little step you took
today and tomorrow and the next day and
the next day you look back those little
micro wins lead to something big let's
move to rule number three master time
management so when you look at
prioritizing it really lives in and I
must say this word and you're probably
not gonna want to hear it but when I
tell you it's a game changer when you
master and just for now begin to operate
inside of time management I use some
resist time management because I'm a
free spirit / people will call me a
rebel back in the day meaning I didn't
want to be controlled I want it I'm a
butterfly I wanted to I wanted to soar I
wanted to be free well the reality is
that when you manage your time more
effectively you actually create more
freedom
that was a huge army somebody's gonna be
ill right now like break through out
loud because when you time manage
meaning I'm gonna use better blocks of
my time let me give you some examples
for that let me use better blocks in my
time meaning I'm only gonna go in my
email three times a day I go on my email
about 9:30 between 9:20 and 9:40 I go in
my email I stay in my email for 30
minutes I'll go back in my email about
three o'clock in the afternoon I stay in
my email again for about thirty minutes
I go back a name one more time at 6:00
p.m. I stay in for about thirty minutes
that's it I don't go in nineteen times I
don't go on twenty times because three
times a day gives me adequate time to
see what's in there see what's new and
act appropriately otherwise it's
throwing me off I'm blocked my day about
ninety minutes each time blocked to do a
task even if a task only takes me 30
minutes I timed like 90 minutes because
I get distracted but when you time block
your day and then you schedule each day
not every day looks the same I have a
time block for everything I need to do
for seven days out of the week can you
believe that in that time I got more
things done you have to become
comfortable with your note my
grandmother says baby
she starts every sentence with baby baby
if you want your yes to have more value
you need to learn how to exercise your
note see your yes might not have this
value anymore why because you give it
away too much you give it to too many
people you give it away too often
you're always over committing and then
you feel drained and frustrated and you
don't have gratitude in your heart
because you're over committed well that
all started with a yes that should have
been enough or should have been a I'd
love to but not now and so number two
number one is more effective time
management that has your agenda in it it
has your priority priorities in it right
now your agenda is covered with everyone
else's task I often I heard once if you
don't have a urine
you're gonna work for somebody else's
agenda and so number one is your time
manager with your agenda and number two
is operating utilizing and being
comfortable in a note and not an
attitude no not to like oh thanks no
like no not that mm-hmm just uh no not
now
you know I I would love to but my plate
is full I'm free in 90 days just don't
make no no energy just not now don't be
surprised when everyone comes to you
you're great you're amazing you're
brilliant look at you you're on this
channel so you know you smart you want a
better life you want an abundant life of
course you're here of course everyone
wants you and your priorities matters so
I think there are two very important
points buried in this rule and I think
it's so important because entrepreneurs
we're working crazy hours to get our
dream off the ground and maybe we have
jobs and family and all this other stuff
happened at the same time and so how do
you balance everything how do you allow
that creativity to come out it's by
scheduling it's by setting aside time
every single day and by creating
different paths for different days so
for me my Monday looks one way my
Tuesday looks one way my Wednesday looks
going away and every week then I repeat
that same thing so Monday my T vs I'm
working on TBS stuff that's that's my
entire day I'm not being distracted by a
bunch of other things and so figuring
out that time management for yourself to
chunk your tasks down to do one thing on
certain days I find at least really
helps me focus and go far so I'm not
just constantly being bombarded and
reacting to other people the second part
was saying no I'm focusing right like
understanding that your goals are your
goals and you're trying to build
something better for yourself and of all
you're doing is reacting to other
people's goals for you then you're
living their life you're helping them
build their empire you're up on them
have a huge impact in your playing small
and so sometimes those things are
aligned sometimes what your friends our
family your partners or colleagues want
you to do is also aligned with what you
want to do and that's where the magic
happens but if it's not then be willing
to say no in a respectful way so that
you can focus on the things that you
will need to get done I love at least
that let's move on to rule number four
leap afraid so we talked about making
your dash
point one you gotta be willing to do it
afraid see you might be waiting for the
fear to stop Lisa I heard this so many
times Lisa I'm afraid what do I do do it
anyway Lisa I'm afraid I don't quite
know if I should move move anyway I
don't know if I should leap leap afraid
and then gather your courage on the way
down and if you don't get it before you
hit you what's gonna hit anyway I'd
rather die leaping then on the edge
figuring out how to get the courage to
leap yes yes yes yes so many times we're
waiting we're waiting I'm waiting I'm
waiting to get something rise I see your
hands going up you guys know if it's
your truth you can raise your hand just
like we did on day zero you're just kind
of waiting you're waiting to get
everything in order you're waiting
you're waiting so that everything is is
Inuits together you're waiting to not be
afraid you're waiting to have the
courage you're waiting to have all the
money you're waiting to lose weight see
see if I waited to release my unwanted
pounds before I got in front of you Lisa
Nichols would be the secret yes yes I
thought how about I just leap with my
imperfection and then find my form of
perfecting my imperfection while I'm
sorry how about I do that
how about I how about you not wait to
get it right
you look at you figure out how does it
look doing it wrong how does that look
because you're 80% of right is somebody
else's hundred and fifty nine percent of
what they needed yes yes and what you
want to do it right and you want to wait
to you not afraid and you want to wait
together all together oh you made it
about you again see Nelson Mandela did
it he just did it not knowing if it were
right Mahatma Gandhi just did it not
knowing if it were right mother Teresa
just did it not looking for affirmation
or confirmation is this right Martin
Luther King did it not even knowing if
it would
before his life ended what are you
waiting on are you willing to do it
afraid are you willing to do it knowing
that you got so much work to do to get
it better to get it more perfect but are
you willing to do it inside your
imperfection do you realize that in your
imperfection you're perfect for the job
I really love this point I think if
you're not scared about some of the work
that you're doing then then you're bored
then then you're not living then you're
racing against three-year-olds if you
know that you're gonna win then your
dreams are too small I think it's really
important that you have something that
challenges you and that concept of don't
feel the fear like just fear is not real
the fear is real recognize the fear and
you jump through the fear because every
great thing that you will ever
accomplish in your life will be on the
opposite side of a big wall of fear so
what are you waiting for let's jump over
it and let's also jump to rule number
five
visualize visualization is a gift to
your heart and your soul it's a gift
because if the the idea is the seed
visualization is the is the it's the
fertilizer it's the fertilizer because
when your thoughts are connected with an
emotion see you would visualize yourself
winning and you would feel all the
emotion that came with that and all
you're doing now is you're not chasing a
foreign emotion you know the feeling and
now you're just doing what's necessary
to get back to that feeling in real time
and so what what a good friend of mine
vision of the CEO of my value you know I
would I did a visualization with him we
were in Bali and he said to me
afterwards I never get emotional yeah
well he was like I cried I got emotional
because I figured it out
it's visualization a good visualization
brings an emotion he was like that's how
you do it and so I love doing
visualizations because and and it's
really important in the visualization
you can't see it over there you have to
see it right here you got to feel it
right here like I am it's all I am I am
I am in my dream home I
in my dream relationship and then unpack
what that looks like but most
importantly unpack what it feels like
and when you have that that emotion in
this moment all of a sudden you stir up
something that I don't think will ever
go back to sleep it'll go ok let's go
get that and what it really does is it
sets up a state of cognitive dissonance
and cognitive dissonance is when you see
something in your mind and you see
yourself in a way that your behaviors
are not currently leading to us so your
mind becomes disrupted and it goes ok
can we get there right it's not there
right now right now and that's not
comfortable your mind wants to literally
be congruent what it thinks is what
you're doing what it thinks is what
you're doing and so when you set up a
constant and abundant thinkers like you
and I we do it unconsciously
we we are constantly keeping ourself in
a state of cognitive dissonance meaning
ok what else and I'm seeing Lisa over
there I'm gonna okay let me go WOW while
being grateful for am I now yeah it's
not in that I'm gonna be holding
complete when I get over there I'm
holding complete now I just know I'm
supposed to be over there so let me do
what's necessary to get over there and
let me let me evict any behaviors or
characteristics that are stopping me and
let me adopt any new ones that I need I
really love this point and I do
visualization I think it's really
helpful and clear to have an
understanding of what you want and every
time I've had a vision for something
specific that I wanted it just started
happening and I got it I haven't had
visualization that though to the point
where I'm crying and overwhelmed with
emotion so I'm gonna I'm gonna think
about this once more I'm gonna look into
it more maybe lisa has some programs on
how to do that effectively or something
coming up but it made me think and I'm
curious to see how that turns out for me
and for you guys who might have done it
I'd love to hear your thoughts in the
comments below too let's keep the ball
rolling rule number six define
prosperity for yourself so when you ask
the class
look at the question how do I create a
life of prosperity when I haven't known
it when my family hasn't known it when
it's not what where it's not what I was
born into you know there many people was
born who were born into prosperity I
wasn't one and you may or may not be one
but how you transform a life or create
lack of prosperity is number one you
identify what does prosperity look like
to you define prosperity by your own
terms and don't make it a global
Universal answer you want to define
prosperity in each area of your life I
know that sounds like it's really
detailed but you cannot hit a moving
target you won't ever hit a moving talks
so the more detail you get the more the
target slows down I think this point
ties in really well to the last one I
think the more you have a clear
understanding of what it is that you
want what what press bertie looks like
to you not to your friends or your your
spouse so your significant other your
family or anybody around you
but what press-ready looks like to you
the clearer that becomes the easier it
is to you actually to go out and make it
happen I love it it's a great point
let's move on the rule number seven
trust your intuition you know when you
want to learn how to trust your
intuition more you know I say and this
is me and my walk and my my belief
system that your intuition is your
internal GPS system your internal God
placement system
it's that whisper and sometimes it's
that screamed that tells you to leap or
to be still your intuition is a
combination of spirit emotion and logic
and it's guiding you and so often we
don't hear our intuition why don't we
hear it because we're having too much
chatter in our head like the chatter in
our head doubt
worried judgment oh my god
judgment are fear fear of other people's
perception of you so your intuition is
saying I love to dance I want to dance I
want to sing your intuition is saying we
can have a great time your intuition
said I want love your intuition is
saying gosh let's go take that chance on
that writing that book or let's take
that chance on starting that business
then your chatter comes in no what if I
fail so let me explain this to you your
mind your brain is designed to keep you
safe
it's designed and it only has the
ability to go back in time in the mental
file cabinet and look at the last time
you tried something like this and it may
not have been good or it may have ended
in some dangerous situations where
people could judge you and your brain is
designed to protect you that's it your
brains desire to protect you is logical
your intuition is that spark of passion
it's that spark of desire it's that
spark of love it's that spark of pull me
forward it's that little bit of radical
it's that a lot a bit of I want to leave
my fingerprint on this planet your brain
isn't designed to have those same IDs
now now your intuition can kick the
brain in and the brake and start
thinking of ways to but the intuition is
where it's gonna start it's in your gut
and see this is why when you feel
something you kind of go here you don't
go oh I feel so special you don't say I
feel special here you say I feel it here
I feel it here and so your job is not to
turn down the doubt your job is to turn
up the passion it's to turn up the faith
is to turn up the possibility now still
make well-thought-out plan I always say
the best plan is the plan made I don't
care if you have to upgrade it you have
to modify it but if you if you if you if
you fail to plan then you plan to fail
so every dream every passion every
desire follow it with a plan because
actually your brain gets excited your
brain goes yes we got a plan now
now you can believe yourself see you set
big goals and dreams and you have
desires and then you don't achieve it
but you don't achieve it because you
didn't set the plan in place you didn't
do the details and then you stopped
believing you could do it then you do
the biggest tragedy you stop dreaming
you stop hoping you stop stretching
yourself you stop listening to your GPS
your God placement system that says
you've been put here on a divine
assignment and your assignment may
change over years guess what your
assignment you had 15 years ago may be
very different from the assignment on
your life today your job is to turn down
the volume in your head the volume of
judgment the volume of fear the volume
of worry the volume of perfection turned
down the volume in your head and turn up
the volume in your intuition then your
solar plex in that God placement system
in that heart space turn up the volume
that place that just says what do I want
what ask yourself this tonight today
tomorrow what feels
and then be still and be quiet I love
this clip it reminds me of a quote in
the new book from Kevin O'Leary from the
shark tanks who said I listen to my gut
it's not an emotion it's an index of
risk and you get it as you age you
become better every year and I think
it's so important that your your gut
gets better the more you listen to it
and the more you trust it if you're
feeling something and you don't act on
it then it's hard to continue to develop
that intuition but you want to be making
the big decisions in life with your
heart and the Swans with your head
big decisions with the heart or your gut
and the small ones with the head because
the head only understands the world that
currently exists what your heart your
gut can create something new and the
more you listen to this the more you
said listen to your heart and your gut
instead of your head that's when things
really start to take off for you
let's move on the rule number eight like
yourself first these to me this is the
road to true freedom I have nothing to
prove mmm I have nothing to protect I
have nothing to hide and I have nothing
to defend mmm that your perception of me
after I tell my truth is actually none
of my business my perception of me that
I go to bed as whole and complete as I
woke up before I check how many likes I
have on Facebook that I like me first
mmm and every other like is bonus very
good market that was a long road to get
to low roads for long road this is
another fantastic clip it reminds me of
Quincy Jones who said not one drop of my
self-worth is dependent on your
acceptance of me and I love that I'm
getting close to that I don't know that
I don't know how you get to that a
hundred percent because somebody's
opinion even if you don't know them even
if you don't respect them it still can
hurt it can still play a role even
though you get a thicker and thicker and
thicker skin as you get bigger as you as
you practices more I'm at least till on
my journey it still bothers me a little
bit and I'd like to learn more ways to
get even better at it so thank you Lisa
for the reminder let's move on the rule
number nine play big I get
ask the question a lot how do I jump
start again when I've been complacent
you know I found that I had to ask
myself this question as well for so many
years I was working hard to feed Jelani
I was working hard to give him an equal
chance I had this goal that by the time
he was 18 I would have transformed our
lives and I ran hard for it and I worked
hard for it and by the time he was 18
our lives were completely transformed
and barely recognizable and I found that
I had slowed down a bit still running
but running at about 70% and the
challenge that you have to watch out for
is that your 70% could be someone else
as a hundred and fifteen percent because
you are such a game changer so you can
impress a lot of people never playing
full-out and you can look up in a years
past three years past five years have
passed and you haven't played full-out
for a while because you've already
achieved a lot by some people's
standards but there's still so much more
that you can do I want to coach you in
this way dream a dream are set a goal
that's big enough to make you get
nervous often times if you're not
setting a goal that's beyond three years
out in front of you there's not enough
to run for so I want you to look at your
goals can you achieve them in a year two
years I want you to set a goal for three
years so to go for five years and set a
goal for ten years yes I said ten years
when I did this phenomenal program
called life book they had me set 10-year
goals and I was so uncomfortable I said
they're silent for a moment I hadn't
thought ten years out about my life but
if you go out far enough ten five
three then all of a sudden you're
playing for something so much bigger and
then set a goal that makes your knees
knock and your teeth chatter a bit if
you know how to get to your goal you're
not dreaming big enough now the goal
also has to be realistic has to be
realistic something you can do if you're
currently making 80,000 then your goal
in three years isn't to make 500,000
unless you have a path that's viable to
get you there that's real the thing
that's really important to remember
about a goal is that if you set lofty
goals that you will never hit because
they're not realistic in the first place
you have to set realistic goals that
doesn't mean you're not capable doesn't
mean that you don't believe in yourself
but realistic goals if you set a bunch
of unrealistic goals and you don't hit
them every time you don't hit a goal you
lose just a little bit of hoping
yourself a little bit of faith in
yourself and then what happens is you
look up five years ten years from now
and you're not dreaming anymore you're
not setting goals anymore you're afraid
to tell anyone so set a goal that makes
your knees knocking your teeth chatter a
bit set a goal that's three years out in
front of you set one that's five years
and set one that's ten years and matter
of fact sets several and all those
timelines and then hook your caboose to
the Train of other people who are
running as fast as you are surround
yourself in a community that inspires
you to want to stand on your tippy toes
they inspire you because they're doing
so much now they believe in values they
believe in faith they believe in family
but they also believe in running hard
playing hard and living big because if
you're the biggest fish in your
community then that's okay you just need
to get a second community to play inside
of as well and so if you find yourself
going hold on I become complacent
walk out 15 years and go do I want to
look back in 15 years and this was the
best that I did the answer probably is
no I love this rule and I think it ties
in really well to rule number two which
was create micro wins
so you're dreaming big we have a big
action plan you want to go and change
the world they have this huge dream for
yourself they think is realistic or nené
shattering but still something you can
accomplish in 3 5 15 years and you
create micro wins you start getting
going on it immediately I think the
biggest threat and Lisa talked about it
here is your potential is not being
reached you are talented you are genius
and allows you to coast and everybody
thinks you're doing a great job and you
just coast it along because you're
really playing at 65% or 70% of what
you're capable
you're not playing full-out because
nobody's pushing you to play full of as
you need to push yourself to do it by
setting big goals that inspire you
regularly
let's finish his awesome video off with
rule number 10 live your quest when we
talk about living our quest and I think
that living my quest really if I look at
on a daily basis it's finding my own
voice it's finding your voice it's
finding the song that only you can sing
off key or not it's finding your rhythm
it's discovering what it feels like to
walk in your shoes today it won't look
like it looked 10 years ago living your
quest is what can I do with my life so
that my life becomes infectious to
someone else living my quest
looks like how do I make my fingerprint
matters so big that it lives beyond my
transition day living your quest is how
can I forgive the perceiving Lea
unforgivable so I can love the absolute
loveable living your quest is how do I
give myself a thousand second chances
and every time I get to 999 press reset
yeah yeah living my quest is is not some
ambiguous untouchable experience living
my quest means going back and healing
the little girl in me so that the woman
can be free it's going back at embracing
the little boy in you so that the man
can show up and give himself permission
to cry when necessary living your quest
is not something that you can't touch
it's not something that requires a stage
or lights or cameras living your quest
is being completing content with who you
are in the dark of the night so who you
are in the middle of the day is all
right
living your quest is as simple as it is
complex living your quest is about
giving yourself permission say
permission on a daily basis to become
the next best version of yourself living
your quest is not holding yourself
hostage to old decisions not holding
yourself hostage to shame blame guilt
regret and anger living your quest is
about recognizing that everyday I can be
reborn to my possibility living your
quest is as internal and personal as it
is public living your quest is about
recognizing that you have brilliance in
you and not being willing to dim your
light one more day living your quest
means not being afraid of the genius in
you even though you have doubt living
your quest is recognizing that you get
to sing your song off tune that you can
get to live in perfection while you
master in perfection I love this clip
it's so beautiful I'm just gonna leave
it as it is thank you Lisa for all the
awesomeness that you continue to share
to inspire people around the world
so thank you guys so much for watching
I'd love to know what was your favorite
rule what message really resonated with
you the most that you're going to apply
immediately in your life or your
business my personal favorite was rule
number one which was disrupt your
standards and I think rule number five
the visualize one is something that I'm
gonna dig into little bit more to
improve on I'd love to know again what
was your favorite and why leave it down
in the comments below
now I made this video because Charmaine
Robinson asked me to if there's a famous
entrepreneur that you would like me to
profile next check out the link in the
description you can go to that video and
leave your vote in the comments and have
your say I also want to give a quick
shout out to Polly matzo Co Polly thank
you so much for picking up a copy of my
book your one word and posting about it
on Twitter and Instagram
I really really appreciate the support
and I hope you enjoyed the read so thank
you guys again for watching I believe in
you I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one where it
is much love
I'll see you soon
so often people are consumed with fear
the fear of judgement that's a huge one
the fear of failure what happens if it
doesn't work the fear of success what
happens if it does work and people see
me like they really see me for who I am
what happens if I get hurt in a
relationship like there's so many
what-ifs
but what happens when you what if
yourself all over yourself you never
think about the what if it works what if
what if it has just them just as much
chance at working as it doesn't not
working and what if you redefine what we
call failure and in my language I love
it in the book abundance now that I
wrote and many of you have read it I
talked about you can fail all day long
just fail forward the only distinction
between a bunch of really successful
individuals and a bunch of individuals
really wanting success is that the
successful individuals we're willing to
fail and they did fail they just failed
forward some of my best lessons are born
out of my failures literally to this day
and my failures these days cost six
figures or more but I'm willing to do
that because I want the lesson or the
outcome and if you allow a failure to
feed your futures what I call feeding
your future meaning what are the two
things that I did really well and what's
the one area that I can improve upon or
what's the three things I did really
well and what are the two areas that I
can improve upon and then take those two
things and pull those that lesson
forward or take the three things that
you did well and make sure you don't
lose those to me the tragedy the tragedy
of when something doesn't go the way you
thought is when you only beat yourself
up from it you never ever look at what
did I do well and where can I improve I
learned from a brilliant brilliant
friend of mine Ivy Meisner that balance
is a myth but harmony is a must see I
write about an abundance now and I
really took a lot of time to open this
up to unpack this and I really want to
recommend that you read that part so
that you can understand
intellectually which will cause you to
make different decisions so when you
seek balance you're seeking to equalize
your entire life you want the same
portions you want to have as much time
with family as you have at work you
would have as much time at play as you
have with family you want to have as
much personal time as you have family
time and if you think about it when you
look at all the quadrants of your life
which I think they're about twelve when
you really break them down some people
say for I like to break them down into
twelve when you look at all those areas
and they're subcategories under
relationship like romantic family
friends and under work and then there's
under health and wellness personal
development self esteem spirituality if
you try to give equal amount to everyone
that's like twelve point something
percent time is it's just unrealistic
especially if you're in a career that's
demanding or God knows if you're an
entrepreneur then it just doesn't happen
so what occurs is we begin to spend our
energy and time pursuing an unrealistic
expectation in the first place setting
ourselves up for constant failure have
you ever thought of pursuing a goal that
you know you'd probably never reach who
wants to do that we do it all the time
when we pursue balance on the other hand
what if you pursued harmony see balance
says I need to equalize everything
harmony says I need to make sure they
learn how to play together and dance
together so that my life overall 360
feels good to live with that let me give
an example how I used to do that so I
would work all day when Jelani was about
six or seven years old well I did I
worked all day when he was 9 10 12 and
14 - but he was 6 and 7 I was just
establishing my company we had just
packed our bags and moved from Los
Angeles I moved away from my nest of my
mom and my dad and my family and my my
cousins and my siblings and now we're by
ourselves in San Diego California and so
I spend all day working really really
hard so that I can ideally make this
dream work but every day seeking harmony
not
every day at 6:29 not stop and from 6:30
until 8:30
that was Jelani and mommy time and
during that Jelani and mommy time I
would do everything
Jelani what do you want to do every day
I'd ask them question what do you want
to do and he had the same answer every
day he wanted to play Monopoly and I
gotta tell you you know my son loves
monopoly and I think I used to like it
but I've played more games of monopoly
we've had monopoly we've had try ah
Polly we've had monopoly with the credit
cards we've had monopoly with dinosaurs
we had monopoly with Pokemon we have
chef ugly because he want to be a chef
we've had every woman monopoly possible
but during that time we had our
connection time and then we cook
together and he would be mustard man and
I would be garlic girl and literally on
my bed today our two pillows one pillow
says mustard man and another pillow says
garlic girl and we made those two hours
matter then I pay them I surprised him
bathing himself and then I put him to
bed and we make up stories together and
we have this thing where he'd start a
story then I add to it then he'd add to
it then I'd add to it and every time he
added to the story someone got hurt and
every time I added to the story
everything worked out fine and he always
tried to kill or sabotage or hurt the
the main character not always trying to
make a happy ending and we would have
this hilarious experience for about 25
minutes and at 8:30 I'd kiss him on his
forehead and I'd go back and I'd work
some more until midnight I truly believe
that the relationship I have with my son
which is not perfect but it's absolutely
breathtakingly beautiful for me it's as
a direct result of me seeking harmony
not valence and so harmony is about the
quality of the time that you spend when
you're doing something are you fully
present are you when you're with someone
are you off of your phone when you're
watching a movie are you connected when
you're having dinner are you discussing
life so harmony is being fully present
and deepening the experience versus
trying to get more time time is
something that's finite you only have 24
hours in a day but boy you can make
those 24 mean a whole
more depending on how you spend the time
raise your standard Apple at the core
its core value is that means that people
your passion can change the way people
not one drop of myself work depends on
your it's supposed to mean I don't ever
give up I'd have to be dead or
completely incapacitated hey believe
nation if you want to see my all-time
favorite top ten rows of success I have
a very special secret video for you
these are the individual clips that I
have personally learned the most from
and applied to my life and my business
check the link in description for
details